.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, ADMIRAL MIKE
ROGERS.
>>> HOUSE REPUBLICANS SAY THEY
ARE MORE UNIFIED THAN EVER AS
THEY COMPLETE A LEADERSHIP
CHANGE WHICH SOME SAY HAS THEM
LEANING FURTHER TOWARD THE PAST
THAN TOWARD THE FUTURE.
NEW YORK'S ELISE STAFANIK, A
FIERCE DEFENDER OF FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WAS ELECTED TO
THE PARTY'S NUMBER-THREE SPOT ON
FRIDAY REPLACING OUTSPOKEN TRUMP
CRITIC LIZ CHENEY.
WHILE THE MOVE IS AIMED TO HELP
REPUBLICANS RECLAIM THE HOUSE
NEXT YEAR, IT ALSO STANDS AS A
POTENTIAL ROADBLOCK FOR MAKING
DEALS WITH DEMOCRATS.
CHRISTINA RUFFINI IS AT THE
WHITE HOUSE WITH THE LATEST.
GOOD MORNING.
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING,
MICHELLE.
PRESIDENT BIDEN MET WITH
REPUBLICANS HERE AT THE WHITE
HOUSE THIS WEEK TO TRY TO WORK
OUT A DEAL ON HIS INFRASTRUCTURE
PLAN.
THE SNAINSTALLATION OF A TRUMP
LOYALIST DOESN'T BIDE WELL FOR
FUTURE DEALS.
>> I WANT TO CONGRATULATE ELISE
STEFANIK AND WELCOME HER TO THE
LEADERSHIP TEAM.
>> Reporter: IN A SECRET BALLOT,
HOUSE REPUBLICANS VOTED TO
INSTALL ELISE STEFANIK AS
CONFERENCE PARTY CHAIR BY AN
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY.
134 TO 46.
REPLACING LIZ CHENEY, ONE OF
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S MOST
PROMINENT REPUBLICAN CRITICS,
WITH ONE OF HIS MORE VOCAL
DEFENDERS.
>> I SUPPORT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
VOTERS SUPPORT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE IS AN IMPORTANT VOICE IN OUR
REPUBLICAN PARTY, AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH HIM.
>> Reporter: EVEN THOUGH HE'S NO
LONGER IN OFFICE, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT REMAINS POPULAR WITH
REPUBLICANS LOOKING TO KEEP
THEIR SEATS.
AND MAYBE TAKE BACK THE HOUSE IN
NEXT YEAR'S MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
>> I ALSO WANT TO THANK
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR HIS SUPPORT.
>> Reporter: STILL BANNED FROM
MAJOR SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS,
MR. TRUMP CONGRATULATED STEFANIK
IN A PRESS RELEASE WRITING THAT
THE MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN
MOVEMENT IS STRONG.
>> AND THE CLAIMS HE'S MAKING TO
UNDERMINE OUR DEMOCRACY HAVE
MADE HIM UNFIT FOR OFFICE.
>> Reporter: CHENEY, ONE OF ONLY
TEN REPUBLICANS WHO VOTED TO
IMPEACH THE FORMER PRESIDENT
AFTER THE CAPITOL RIOTS, SAID
YESTERDAY THAT INSTALLING A
TRUMP LOYALIST IN LEADERSHIP
PUTS THE GOP IN PERIL.
>> I DON'T BELIEVE THAT HE
SHOULD BE THE LEADER OF THE
PARTY.
AND HE HASN'T EXPRESSED ANY
REMORSE OR REGRET FOR JANUARY
6th.
>> Reporter: YESTERDAY HOUSE
MEMBERS AGREED TO CREATE A
9/11-STYLE COMMISSION TO
INVESTIGATE THE ASSAULT ON THE
CAPITOL.
THE PANEL WILL INCLUDE FIVE
DEMOCRATS AND FIVE REPUBLICANS.
AND THAT PANEL REMAINS
CONTROVERSIAL WITH REPUBLICANS
WHO SAY THE PARTY NEEDS TO FOCUS
ON MOVING FORWARD.
SPEAKING OF MOVING FORWARD,
PRESIDENT BIDEN WILL TRAVEL TO